this is from the Hamburg police they
have said that a fire has broken out in
a storage facility with possible
chemicals and toxins in the Smoke they
say that smoke cloud is moving towards
the center of the city and they can't
say at the moment the extent of the
danger and that danger would be due to
toxins in that cloud they've said that
so far 140 people have been evacuated in
the surrounding area they say avoid the
area drive around it if possible
find out in the media for example in
local radio tell your neighbors and they
will let you know when the danger has
passed
only dial one one zero the police on 112
the fire brigade in emergencies keep all
access routes to the Fireside clear
close your windows and your drawers turn
off your ventilation and air
conditioning pay attention to
loudspeaker announcements and yeah close
those windows and doors immediately and
if you're in the area in question switch
the ventilation to recirculation
immediately and leave the area please
also notify your neighbors particularly
those who may need assistance due to
disabilities language barriers or
reduced Mobility so that is the latest
from the Hamburg fire brigade so after
the Hamburg police said that a fire has
broken out in a storage facility with
possible chemicals in Smoke and that
smoke cloud is moving towards the center
of the city obviously a developing
situation and will keep you up to date
with what's happening in Hamburg